[Applaudissements]
alors donc un jour ce fameux jour
j'étais en réunion parents professeurs
et donc j'ai exposé mon programme
d'éducation à la paix que j'allais
proposer à mes élèves cette année là et
puis vient le moment où les parents
prennent la parole et arrive la phrase
fatidique
non mais madame on n'est pas dans un
monde de bisounours 1 qu'est ce que j'ai
pu l'entendre cette phrase encore
partout tout le temps dès que je
commence à parler de résolution de
conflits d'éducation bienveillante de
paix j'entends cette phrase encore et
encore alors je me suis demandé c'est
quoi le monde des bijoux dans la tête
des gens est ce que c'est un monde
merveilleux où tout va tout le temps
bien c'est tout le monde est gentil où
il se passe jamais rien aucun problème
parce qu'en réalité ils ont des conflits
si si c'est juste qu'ils arrivent à les
régler sans violence
les conflits sont bénéfiques en fait
pour la relation la violence non alors
pourquoi les gens n'aiment pas le monde
des bisounours pour soi c'est tout de
suite tourner en dérision considérés
comme n'ayant nyon ou utopiste
bon admettons un moment que ça ne fasse
plus peur à personne
et voyant comment nous pourrions faire
pour aller vers mende un peu plus en
paix selon moi il faut d'abord
s'intéresser aux violence éducative
ordinaire
en fait ce sont toutes les violences du
quotidien qui sont tolérés par la
société il ya les violences physiques
la tap la fessée les violences verbales
le les cris les insultes et les
violences psychologiques comme la
manipulation le chantage
alors j'en discutais avec quelqu'un et
puis tout de suite personne à ses nerfs
m dit ouais mais non mais n'importe quoi
- j'ai reçu des fessées d'abord quand
j'étais enfin et puis ça va quoi j'en
suis pas mort et puis façon c'est comme
ça le monde y est dure voilà quoi il ya
des choses beaucoup plus graves dans la
vie sain
les enfants qui se font battre abuser ça
va quoi c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai dit
tout a tout à fait raison
les maltraitances et dramatique en fait
il faut considérer ces petites violences
comme le terreau des grandes
maltraitance et en ça elles sont tout
aussi dramatique
c'est une escalade en fait on commence
par la main ensuite on va prendre le
ballet ni eau ont commencé à taper
de plus en plus fort on arrive sur la
maltraitance et parfois jusqu'à la mort
il faut savoir qu'en polynésie française
il y a un taux de violence
intrafamiliale particulièrement élevé et
que un enfant meurt quasiment tous les
cinq jours de violences dans les pays
francophones
alors tout le monde parle de paix en
fait mais personne n'est dupe vraiment à
la paix vous propose de faire un petit
tour d'horizon pour voir sens en
commençant par la naissance on provoque
on utilisait forceps on sépare on laisse
un bébé pleurer mais c'est pour cent
bien ça va je trouve ça c'est notre ange
façon de prendre soin ou de montrer son
amour à quelqu'un heureusement que je
connais des professionnels de santé qui
croient eux aussi au monde des
bisounours
puis bébé grandit est ce que vous vous
souvenez de ce jour où vous avez dû vous
en séparer alors qu'il avait à peine
deux mois
deux petits mois et ensuite on ne cesse
de s'en séparer encore la garderie
l'école les activités extrascolaires le
camp de vacances tout ça ce sont des
ruptures à la relation d'attachement qui
peuvent être vécues comme violente et
puis quand on est ensemble on est pressé
on est tout le temps précieux
dépêche-toi la société ne respecte pas
nos rythmes naturels les réveille matin
sont violents
arrive à halloween et les bonbons bien
avec savez le taux de sucre est
directement liée à notre taux
d'agressivité
il ya aussi les costumes alors moi
j'avais choisi le costume trop mignon de
petits pirates à doha un petit pirate un
petit pirate vous voulez dire en fait un
pilleur de bateaux quittent russie tout
le monde c'est quoi déjà le modèle que
je veux offrir à mes enfants
alors on va chanter le premier qui rira
aura une et bam violences
physiques puis un jour ils demandent un
fusil en plastique ou le dernier jeu
vidéo de guerre à la mode
bon vous savez les fusils ils sont
arrivés en même temps que les premières
guerres ces mêmes guerre que l'on voie d
un intrigant en dix ans dans mais quelle
horreur
je sais je sais je sais c'est difficile
de dire non dans une société où tout le
monde fait comme ça moi même j'ai subi
huit ans de harcèlement intensifs un de
la part de mon fils j'ai tenu et puis un
jour j'ai lâché j'ai lâché prise
j'ai lâché quand il a compris pourquoi
dans le monde des bisounours on jouait
pas au fusil en plastique et surtout
quand il a pu faire son propre choix
ensuite ils vont à l'école
huit heures par jour alors il ya les
copains qui joue à la bagarre les gros
mots il y a le harcèlement la popularité
et les rejets qui vont avec
il ya une note il ya la compétition
cette compétition si importante dans
notre société on me dit ouais mais tu
sais le monde c'est un monde de requins
c'est comme ça il faut se battre si dur
voilà à quoi aucun pas bisounours
pourtant il me sens comme que l'école
est le premier pas vers ce monde réel
alors je trouve que ça si ça c'est sympa
que cette école soit le reflet justement
du monde dans lequel nous voudrions que
nos enfants grandissent plus tard il ya
un truc important aussi chez business
c'est le symbole qui assurent leur
ventre ils ont un différend chacun et
ensemble ils les combines comme un répit
au pilon un pouvoir
il arrive à surmonter leurs épreuves ça
aussi je trouve ça intéressant pour
notre société où on veut tous
standardisés mettre dans des cases
tu es en train de me dire là qui va
falloir que je fasse 30 cours différents
pour mes 30 élèves différents non mais
ça va pas ben je sais oui la différence
c'est compliqué ça prend du temps ça
demande aussi beaucoup de créativité et
la créativité ça apporte beaucoup de
joie est joyeux et productif en même
temps on n'est pas dans le monde de
bisounours a pourtant il ya des grandes
entreprises qui l'ont déjà compris
google et bien d'autres
c'est ce qu'on appelle le concept
gagnant gagnant heureusement je connais
aussi les profs bisounours
je pourrais continuer comme ça pendant
des heures et des heures
et puis je sais que c'est désagréable se
rend compte à quel point on est cerné
par la violence y en a partout en vain
et en même temps je trouve ça important
que l'on puisse repérer l'ennemi
justement pour pouvoir s'en défendre
donc je vous invite quand même à
observer dans votre quotidien
tout ce qui va à l'encontre de vos
besoins naturels votre rythme tout ce
qui va à l'encontre de ce qui vous rend
heureux parce qu'en fait c'est tout ça
qui est violent vous avez déjà entendu
parler du fait que la violence engendre
la violence
c'est un cycle en fait lorsque l'on tape
un enfant de la fessée dans lui apprend
que la violence est un moyen de résoudre
ces problèmes puis nous quand on grandit
et bien on dès qu'on est en contact avec
des enfants est battu qu'on a appris
dans l'enfance on est c réactive et tout
ça on est dans un cycle vous saupoudrez
ses croyances là d'un peu de culture
d'un peu de religion un peu de aussi
mécanismes de défense comme le déni et
vous avez que d'amy
nerfs après on en est encore là bon
allez c'est chez tout ça on va au ciné
on va voir le dernier film qui vient de
sortir une super héros bah tu vois ça
c'est cool les super héros il sauve le
monde voit la super héros qui tuent des
supers méchants à l'aide de leur super
coup de poing parce qu'en fait même
cette notion de gentils et de méchants
elle est violente et pourquoi tu es ce
que vous avez déjà été méchant imaginez
moi je suis dans ma voiture
bon je roule un peu vite et ça va je
respecte l'ami de vitesse et puis bah je
cogne le rétroviseur d'une moto qui
passe à côté de moi alors le gars il
m'insulte il perd ça chez moi je suis
tout désolé je pars demain il avancé feu
vert ça passe très vite du mois ça
continue à tendre matin tu mens pardon
je suis désolé j'ai pas fait exprès je
pense exprès alors il est qu ils
pourront parler comme ça ça vous est
déjà arrivé et vous aviez une bonne
raison de faire ce que vous aviez fait
moi ce jour là j'avais une poubelle qui
enquêtait sur la route et donc j'avais
dû serrer à gauche en nier la
psychologie humaniste de laquelle
découle la communication non-violente la
parentalité positive l'éducation bien
brillantes
cet épisode est bien elle part du
principe que l'homme il est
fondamentalement bon ouais genre tous
les hommes
non mais n'importe quoi même celui là
qui m'a menti volet insultes mêmes
lituaniens qu'il est bon et même un
serial killer ça veut dire qu'il est bon
ça je sais je sais il sait du bisounours
bien lourd
même moi parfois j'ai du mal à dire mais
oui oui l'idée c'est qu'on a tous une
bonne raison de faire ce que l'on fait
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intention
positive
et cette intention positive pour arriver
à la déceler chez quelqu'un même si le
tap le pire individus qu'ils soient en
fait on a besoin d'empathie et de
compassion et la compassion des
scientifiques l'ont prouvé c'est ce qui
mène au bonheur
on sait tous que les scientifiques sont
pas des bisounours en fait le monde y
est pas tout noir ou tout blanc tout ça
c'est un leurre saviez vous que harmony
est une déesse grecque fille de
aphrodite déesse de l'amour et de ares
dieu de la guerre
amour et guerre yin et yang
en fait c'est ça on est tous tout à la
fois en même temps on peut être ferme et
bienveillant on peut se faire respecter
sont adressées on peut croire au monde
des bisounours et avoir les pieds sur
terre il ya toujours une part de gentils
chez un méchant il y a toujours une
girafe qui se cache derrière un chacal
ce qui est certain en fait c'est l'élan
positif qui anime chacun de nos besoins
et donc les comportements qui en
découlent cette conception est né dans
les années 40 aux états unis et à cette
même époque elle plus de mal à percer en
europe parce qu'en fait c'était une
période de guerre
ensuite chaque pays a eu ses propres
circonstances humaines et historiques
qui ont fait que l'évolution des
consciences c'est fait ou pas
aujourd'hui on le voit les pays qui ont
légiféré contre les violences physiques
et psychologiques ont eu des avancées
époustouflante
on le voit on est tous responsables de
cette évolution des consciences et les
grands tant qu aujourd'hui on considère
les enfants pour ce qu'ils sont c'est à
dire le monde de demain notre futur
alors atteint ça veut dire que tu en
train de me dire là qu'il faut laisser
tout faire que c'est la porte ouverte à
n'importe quoi que d'abord c'est même
pas vrai parce que moi et bien dans mon
époque les enfants il obéit au doigt et
à l'oeil
et puis moi mes parents ils brillent
moins élevé à dur et puis j'avais bien
méritée donc voilà c'est beau la loyauté
familiale
en fait on a l'impression qu'à partir du
moment où on va on va lâcher le pouvoir
sur l'autre
eh bien on va tomber dans le laxisme et
puis ça va être le chaos
en fait c'est vite oublier que la
liberté implique la responsabilité et la
responsabilité c'est ça la clé c'est la
clé qui évite les enfants rois et la
délinquance
pas besoin de prison pas besoin de
punition
le pouvoir avec l'autre c'est ça qui est
efficace et pérenne
en fait on part aussi du postulat que
l'enfant il a déjà tout en lui c'est ce
qu'on appelle le potentiel humain
on a souvent l'idée que l'enfant est
mauvaise nous manipuler feignants et
fait des caprices le l'idée c'est que du
coup nous adultes
on doit le remplir de savoir et puis le
redresser sur le bon chemin
en fait ils ont déjà tout en eux donc
finalement on n'a pas besoin de tout ça
cette conception est l'aîné de la
psychanalyse classique qui est
aujourd'hui est mise en lumière avec les
neurosciences affective et sociale
enfin enfin le soutien de la science la
générosité la douceur la gentillesse
tout ça c'est souvent perçus comme des
faiblesses dans notre société
ouais le monde il est dur tu l'aimés
dans une bulle sarah ben voila quoi
c'est pas comme ça c'est pas la vraie
vie quoi je dis il faut les préparer à
affronter tout ça voilà quoi je me dis
en tout cas moi je crée ma propre
réalité
il me je dis qu'on peut tous le faire et
dans ma réalité
eh bien je rencontre tous les gens tous
les jours des gens aillent trop
qui justement ne cède pas face à la
violence des mots ou des gestes parce
qu'il faut être fort en fait très très
fort pour ne pas céder et avoir faire
preuve d'empathie face à un gros but qui
nous prend la tête
la vraie question c'est de se demander
pourquoi nous sommes si attachés à ce
monde dur et cruel
peut-être parce qu'on a ça a été
difficile pour nous on a souffert et
donc on veut préserver nos enfants on
veut qu'il soit prêt à affronter tout ça
en tant que parent veut le meilleur pour
nos enfants
donc si je vous propose est de faire
mieux que ce que l'on a vécu
si je vous disais que le rôle de parents
aux éducateurs c'est pas d'en durcir nos
enfants c'est plutôt d'adoucir ce monde
et de le rendre plus facile pour eux
qu'il ne l'a été pour nous ici je vous
propose est de faire en sorte que ce
monde des bisounours devienne une
réalité
merci pour eux
[Musique]